Trump's decision to authorize the deadly
strike faces criticism from Democrats on
the campaign trail and in Congress ed
O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill and how are
lawmakers responding this morning
well good morning Jericka Democrats
don't question whether or not general
Soleimani was an enemy of the United
States they're just upset that the
administration didn't seek congressional
authorization before taking those steps
take for example Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer aides tell me he didn't
get a heads-up about this before it
happened neither did other top leaders
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi condemned the
president's actions saying America and
the world cannot afford to have tensions
escalate to the point of no return and
chairman of the House Foreign Affairs
Committee alien Engel said the attack
raises serious legal problems he says
according to the War Powers Resolution
the president is required by law to
notify Congress within 48 hours on the
other side of the aisle Republicans are
calling it a success in justice for the
American troops killed at the hands of
general Soleimani through the years
Senator Lindsey Graham a close ally of
President Trump said quote if Iran
continues to attack America and our
allies they should pay the heaviest of
prices which includes the destruction of
their oil refineries and quickly we
should point out today marks one month
until the Iowa caucus candidates will be
holding more than 50 events in that
state for the weekend Tony this is
likely now to be a big topic of
conversation
indeed ed thank you very much
you